за халітова як урок схопивши стати
враховуємо французькою
але ці плани грека радикально
змінило краї за better when повстяний
muted
і за рубля я на тему з тестом
стріт-арт у кіл руб і цілих аль на
однієї пари важливо цінне легально
такий можуть і за раді кошти тас
протесту в кварталах битних базару так
сни даних від вони душі у хуч та іншу
на тему щури allows ще амалію тача
інакше 100 suite щури я не люблю
банальних політичних statement of про
тому місці хоч зображаю кросовер мови та
ки дарує людям знайди початку щура
в афінах куди не глянь графіті доби
важливо бейдж обама іскра ти в них осло
просто ндс прав укрити
подібна нікого іншалла політика носи
кувати таку світові і sprayer eprom
є своїм і графіті по всьому місцю
їх не роботи ваш konapun це ти один
заспівав на ліфті та сцени хроніст щура
clips своїх рахіть вин полю [ __ ] і
малювати навік нах закинутих будемо ними
часто цсж ночі фігури пекло приклад від
тебе статуя з революційним прапором то
коктейлем молотова астані робота бліп зі
карикатура вона неолібералізм уряду то
його так дзвони соціальні дивіденди
кричачи ким і в даному ага its a snow за
висновок і душі рухледів
cost of tanks викладаю більше тих людей
давно б зрубати не
а божих не прабу так скоро ти всю ніч
подачки у 500 євро їх нагріту
c нічого не змінити грунт снайпу лоджій
зі щік риза вийняла важа я таким
долі врятували навіщо засвітом я кому в
сили. liberty
street art point i beg офіційний вигляд
політикою the mass media
сам залишається символом одного струменя
наприклад я як ти викликалася
праворадикали
ми з тіста і активізм може дієти
спільна ми з тестом оживити їх роботи
соціальну роль - і годинник голим позивач
створив і для музеїв та галерей та
обожнюємо з тіста треба творить і для
людей
афіни ясна прикидаються на свій рідний
музики чи відкритим небом між способом і
творіння то похід ньому знак зія я
перерву
диким йти абсолютно легально завдає
графіті на місцях спеціальні види
виданих місцям че приватним та очей на
команд як наприклад
інша клей прахова своє обличчя йогу
роботи чина-най пам'ятний ший в афінах та
Наташка ще зображуючи щура проте
лягавий давиш не фрески the aged пупса
політичних активістів
цін небо та земля місця обидва чаю прикрасити
і часто ну нову в романську волю
нової дібровин та культури так про
світом амалія циpку початківцям
офіційний дози вікові нитки від еви
прибрала батьками саяка завантажувала
прикинься, а назвав ще
ТЕПЕР CQ проти команді бургомістра або
виду я за крима і
за стріт-арт
jeunesse щурів розум його лаберж активних
праці неграмотний
у публічні справи моє опитування легко вийму
зв'язок між скаженим кіль кістки
графіті та паз і на ньому активність та
громадян
он і вислухати і нову нову за
вираз потреба змініть стару модель
у ціни рот не погас азула ви медузи
медуза c особливий пацюк грег і я каперси
ще ми як винний і по горах у
всі ми можемо це ще їсти хороший софт
після цього залишиться какао розум з
друзями і дали ск резюме стиму люба там
і одне слово love as хмари
його ненавидь пишуть південь згадав курив їх
не послання честь тут не так